[Music]
mascots do a lot for selling and
publicizing brands and have played a
major role in marketing for many years
watch until number one to see how mr.
clean has changed over the years if this
is your first time visiting the things
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up here are
10 famous product mascots then versus
now Tony the Tiger
which animal comes to mind if we stay
just two simple words cereal and girl
rates if you guessed Tony the Tiger the
newer absolutely right this mascot is
one of the most popular and recognized
because of his amazing vocals he also
has a signature catchphrase and friendly
look that appealed to both parents and
children when Tony first graced grocery
shelves in the 1950s he looks similar
but not identical to the tiger we
recognized today instead his head was
more of a football shape and his eye
color was green instead of the current
yellow Pat white color toy was created
by Leo Burnett in 1951 originally Tony
the Tiger was designed to target moms
who would the main grocery shoppers at
the time and their children however in
recent years advertising to children
especially when it came to sugary
breakfast cereal came with restrictions
as a result
Tony developed into an increasingly
muscular athletes Kellogg's has even
changed to their advertising audience to
dads who have become the primary shopper
of the household according to an ad H
article one thing that has remained the
same until recently however is Tony's
voice up until his death they're all
ravenscroft's the same man who's saying
you're a mean one mr. Grinch was
responsible for Tony's voice energizer
bunny if we say batteries few of us
would think about the cylindrical items
you can buy at the pharmacy or hardware
store as we have grown so used to
rechargeable batteries in fact unless
it's a hashtag throwbackthursday we
might pay very little attention to these
kinds of batteries which is why having a
recognizable mascot has been a game
changer for energizer we're talking
about the pink flip-flop sunglass
wearing bunny that first walked across
TV screens in 1989 while beating a drum
this bunny is true to his catchphrase
and really does keep going and going
going so much so that he required a
millennial update in order to appeal to
a more contemporary audience energizer
has recreated the bunny while making
sure he maintains recognizable features
so as not to harm the brand now the
bunny has a wider range of motion softer
fur and more human-like facial
expressions making him resemble a
human's movement even his half is a bit
different
energizer also used the opportunity to
update their catchphrase too simply
still going this mascots popularity is
massive and includes spoofs from
Saturday Night Live and the creation of
an energizer bunny float in the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade Tilbury Doughboy
Pillsbury Doughboy first became the
baking company's mascot in 1965 and a
lot of thought and money was put into
the little character the concept came
from trying to make an approachable and
friendly hopper Philips similar to a
delicious piece of dough thus poppin
fresh or as we know him the Pillsbury
Doughboy was created in his debut poppin
fresh was created by using stop-motion
or a claymation and the puppet used to
make him cost $16,000 his voice also
involved a lot of thought as fifty
different voice actors were considered
for the part clearly attention to detail
was the way to go as pop'n'fresh remains
the helpful adorable mascot we recognize
today by his chef hat blue eyes and soft
bookable belly his little giggle also
adds to audiences nostalgia that
surrounds Pillsbury products today
poppin fresh is completely animated and
interacts with products and people in
commercials this is intentional to make
him an essential component of the ad as
a result it's nearly impossible to think
about the brand without picturing poppin
fresh this is clearly a successful ad
campaign that has stood the test of time
thanks to this giggling mascot Pillsbury
is now sold in approximately 30
countries including India Latin America
Germany Austria and Israel windy fast
food restaurant Wendy's derived its name
from their mascot Windy was based on the
nine-year-old daughter of the food
chains founder Dave Thomas naturally as
the restaurant evolved and aged it
became time to revamp Wendy's look in
2013 Wendy's logo changed from an old
fashioned more Western boxy look
more colorful updated look in a newer
design windy space is more prominently
framed as she even looks older her
recognizable red pigtails are still
center stage there is even been
speculation about the subliminal message
included in the design some people began
to notice that Wendy's new collar
now spells out the word mom however
Wendy's senior vice president has denied
that this was intentional meanwhile this
accidental message actually works quite
well with Wendy's overall brandy nut
posts that it's fast food that tastes
more like mom's cooking or at least that
it's fast food mom will approve of
Wendy's appeal continues to be popular
and is even taking on its own life among
Internet artists ever since Wendy's
showed some sass and Twitter comments
against other fast food chains artists
have been posting drawings of windy
reimagines has a sassy and adorable
anime character Larry from Quaker Oats
with a shopping demographic becoming
increasingly health-conscious many food
products have been updating their
marketing strategies to appear healthier
Quaker Oats is definitely one such
company while the Quaker Oats products
have remained the same Larry has
received a very subtle makeover if you
look closely at Larry's collar you will
be able to notice that he looks about
five pounds thinner and a bit younger
though oats are absolutely healthy the
brand's decisions to make a couple
tweaks to their beloved mascot stems
from a concern that consumers might be
deterred if a chubbier face is on a food
product although larry is still wearing
the same outfit his jaw is a bit more
pronounced and his hair is slightly
shorter the font on the box is also
slightly different to give it a more
modern stylistic look Michael Connors
the vice president of design at horn all
Anderson stated in a Wall Street Journal
report that the changes were
intentionally subtle in the hopes that
few people would notice them we want to
hear what you think about this change in
the comments below would an overweight
mascot turn you off from buying a
product even if it was healthy to begin
with Ronald McDonald McDonald's decision
to makeover their red-haired clown
mascot came from a new marketing
strategy based on launching a social
media marketing campaign naturally the
changing landscape of how consumers
interact with brands demand that
companies ensure their mascots evolve
with the times however people are
extremely overwhelmed with
McDonald's new Twitter ready look ronald
traded in his yellow jumpsuit for yellow
cargo pants and a vest over a striped
red and white rugby shirts for formal
events he has an alternate look with a
red blazer and bowtie the pocket of the
blazer sports mcdonald's recognizable
golden arches this design wasn't just
created by anyone but by Tony
award-winning theatrical costume
designer for Beauty and the Beast and
cold war further complications arose for
the clown's due to two contemporary
issues the first problem had to do with
terrifying clown sightings that arose
all over North America this resulted in
Ronald McDonald having to lay low and
wait out the negative reputation crown
imposters we're generating we're
assuming that the popularity of the it
movie also caused the clown's reputation
some harm the second obstacle has to do
with the use of a clown as a mascot for
unhealthy fast food for this reason
Ronald McDonald has been doing most of
his marketing work for the Ronald
McDonald charity foundation Jolly Green
Giant in 1928 the original Jolly Green
Giant was a white man who had a giant
pea pod in his arms this was inspired by
a recent discovery of a giant pea in
England the design for the original
Jolly Green Giant was inspired by the
Brothers Grimm fairy tales that were
popular as of the early 1800s the Jolly
Green Giant received his signature color
and size in 1935 thanks to Leo Burnett
advertising company this new version of
the Jolly Green Giant was everything as
new and current name promised him to be
as he appeared happy and to be of
service in his large green form his new
look came complete with the backstory he
was from the Jolly Green Valley where
his job was to oversee the healthy
growth of the crops not only is this
jovial colorful mascot responsible for
the revolutionary way of preserving
vegetables through caning and freezing
but he has also become a pop culture
icon if you find yourself in Blue Earth
Minnesota you can check out the Green
Giant Museum every summer the town
celebrates the giant Days Festival and
parade that includes giant painted green
footprints on sidewalks it's also
possible to purchase vintage merchandise
as well as visit the 55 foot statue of
the Jolly Green Giant
mr. peanut in 1916 planters chocolate
and nut company ran a contest for the
public to submit designs for the new
peanut mascot the winner of this contest
ended up being a 14 year old from
Suffolk Virginia named Antonio genteel
the entry was a sketch of a mr. peanut
with a cane the graphic design artist
added some iconic features like the top
hat and monocle and the mr. peanut we
know today was born mr. penis popularity
surged immediately he even played a role
in World War two when the u.s. entered
the conflict an army version of mr.
peanut was featured on the propaganda
posters and stamps mr. peanut has a much
more slender and refined look now the
peanut ridges that used to cover his
whole body are now only shaved on the
front of his lower torso in the most
recent version he's also frequently
wearing white gloves a white shirt a
black tie a vexed and black leggings mr.
peanut is such a famous mascot in 2013
the Smithsonian admitted a cast iron
version of the mascot into its National
Museum of American History Gentiles
families submitted his original sketches
to be added to the exhibit as well mr.
met the famous mascot has some recent
controversy surrounding it
mr. Meck made his debut on the cover of
the baseball teams gear book in 1963 and
made his first real-life appearance a
year later the man responsible for mr.
Mehta original design was the art
director and graphic designer at a
Manhattan advertising agencies J Walter
Thompson he thought he'd create a mascot
that resembled a caricature of a human
this is where the idea of a baseball in
the place of the head came from the
original sketches ended up at the Mets
hat office and it was decided that he
would be the team's mascot the design
became much more refined adding baseball
diamonds for pupils updating the uniform
and using the Mets baseball cap instead
of the original orange cap despite mr.
Mets massive popularity in America he
has recently stirred up quite a
controversy when his frustration got the
best of him during the game heckling
fans will frequently blue at games
especially when their team is an
achieving desired results at one events
mr. mat had had enough and reacted by
flipping off the haters in the crowd
this went viral in the metro
reported that the employee representing
the mascot at the time had been fired as
a result mr. clean one of the reasons
mr. clean made it to our number one spot
is because he underwent several mascot
makeovers mr. clean was designed to
advertise Procter & Gamble's cleaning
product the concept of mr. clean came
from the back of the product promised to
clean like magic as a result the idea of
magic in a bottle spawned as a design
for a bald attractive male mascot with a
signature gold genie like earring when
he first appeared in TV commercials with
his very own jingle in 1958 mr. clean
products became the number-one cleaner
in the United States for decades mr.
clean has resonated with consumers who
have seen him as non-threatening and
dependable however many people have
speculated about the mascots sexual
orientation and in a 2017 Super Bowl
commercial mr. clean was even seen
seductively dancing with a mop the
cleaning company tried to explain their
mascots origin and was met with a lot of
negative reactions to a creepy CGI child
version of the man we are used to seeing
finally the biggest change was also in
2017 when Procter & Gamble opted to
trade in their animated white version of
mr. clean for Mike Jackson what do you
think about the evolution of mr. clean
and that's all for the ten famous
product mascots then versus now make
sure to like this video and subscribe to
the things to catch more videos like
this thanks for watching
[Music]